That looks like
a head for a giraffe.
Looks like a rainbow wand.
Looks like a king caterpillar
and the same on there.
Our brains are constantly trying to
make sense of the world around us.
In this activity, you and your
kids will look for familiar shapes
in random patterns and learn about
how our brains process
the things we see.
Have you never been in the park
when you've looked up to the sky
and you've looked at the clouds
and you've seen funny shapes.
Can you imagine what kind
of shapes you will have seen in the clouds?
A duck.
- Yup.
I've definitely seen a duck
at some point. What other shapes?
Mouse.
- Possibly. Or an elephant?
You’ve probably
looked up at the sky
and spotted shapes
in the clouds before.
Even though we know there
really isn’t a duck or a mouse,
our brains are always
scanning for shapes and objects
that we recognise from everyday life.
Talking about this familiar idea is
a really good way to get the activity going.
Phoebe, look at all these paints.
I want you to choose one or two colours
and then we'll splat them on a paper.
Fold the paper over and then see
if we can see any shapes. OK?
So try putting some on.
And then we turn it over.
Oh wow.
What do you think?
Can you see anything there?
Ooh yeah! That one
looks like a bit like a fish
and that one looks like a foot.
Like a foot.
- With two little toes.
These patterns might remind you
of the classic ‘inkblot test’
that was once used to try and tell
things about people’s personalities
according to what shapes they saw.
Psychologists have
long-since stopped using this,
so this experiment is not about trying
to infer anything about your child’s psyche.
Instead it’s about raising
interesting ideas about
why we find it so easy
to see shapes in random patterns,
experimenting, and having fun.
Ooh.
- Ooh.
Next time I think we should
put the blobs there
and then fold it
over without mixing it up
and see what shapes we get.
OK, let's do it.
Encourage your children to think
of different ways to change the paintings.
They could add more colours,
fold the paper in a different way,
or mix the colours together.
And see what colour it makes
and also see what shape it makes.
By doing this, they’re getting used to
changing different factors in an experiment,
and it might get them thinking about
how they recognise objects in real life.
That way looking it looked
like a potato with two ears.
A potato with two ears!
We see shapes and objects in the
random patterns because our brains
are so well designed to spot and
remember objects and animals in real life.
It’s sort of a short-cut our brains
use to process the world quickly,
but it can sometimes mean
we see things in unexpected places.
Did you find it easier to see
more shapes with all the colours
or easier with just the one colour?
Easier with loads of colours.
Do you?
And why is that?
Because I think it would
make a different shape.
Encourage your children to think
about which shapes are easiest to see,
what affects how easy it is,
and why this might be.
Questions like these will get them
thinking more deeply about the activity,
and may help them appreciate how our
brains make sense of the things we see.
So do you think you're
seeing a butterfly in that shape
because you know what a butterfly looks
like and that you like butterflies
and you think about butterflies?
- Yeah.
Which ones do you think
have created the best shapes?
That one and the flower.
You see a flower.
- Yeah.
But when I look at it, I see
a person jumping up, didn't I?
So why do you think I can see a
person jumping up but you can see a flower?
Because it's just like...
When the paintings are all dry,
try adding detail with a pen
to make the shapes
look even more life-like.
And next time you’re in the park,
look up at the clouds
and see what shapes you can spot.
We've had a great time this afternoon
with all the paint and mess.
If you'd like to try it for yourself,
then you can go the Ri website
for more information
and don't forget to like and subscribe.